we're asked to construct an angle
bisector for the given angle so this is
the angle they're talking about and they
want us to make a line that goes right
in between that angle that divides that
angle into two two angles that have
equal measure that have half the measure
of the first angle so let's first find
two points that are equidistant from
this point right over here on each of
these rays so to do that so to do that
let us let us add let's draw one circle
here and I can make this of any radius
wherever this intersects with the Rays
that's where I'm going to put a point so
let's let's say here and here notice
both of these points since they're both
on this circle are going to be
equidistant from this point which is the
center of the circle now what I want to
do is construct a line construct a line
that is equidistant from both of these
points and we've done that already when
we looked at perpendicular bisectors for
lines in this in this construction
module so let's do that so let's add
there compass and so what I want to do
this circle is centered at this point
and it has a radius equal to the
distance between this point and that
point and then I do that again so this
circle is centered at this point and has
a radius equal to the distance between
that point and that point and then the
two places where they intersect are
equidistant to both of these points
they're equidistant to both of these
points and so we can now draw our angle
bisector just like that and you might
say well how do we how do we really know
how do we really know that this angle is
equal to this angle well there's a
couple of ways we can tell we know this
distance right over here is equal to
this distance right over there we know
that this distance over here is equal to
this distance over here and both of
these triangles share this line so you
have essentially if you look at this
point at this point at this point that
forms a triangle and if you look at this
point this point at this point that
forms a triangle we know those two
triangles are congruent so this angle
must be equal to this angle these are
the corresponding
so they're going to be congruent this is
a angle bisector